say this tragedy unfolded yesterday
afternoon just after four o'clock in the
water here just off Bournemouth Beach at
a time when the beach would have been
packed with families enjoying the nice
weather it was a major incident
involving Coast Guard helicopters air
ambulances police lifeboats who all
responded to reports of people in
difficulty in the water in total 10
people were recovered from the scene C
eight people treated for
non-life-threatening injuries but two
people were told to send critical
injuries they were this 17 year old boy
in a 12 year old girl they were taken to
hospitals here in Bournemouth and Poole
where they sadly later died now Dorset
police have launched an investigation
and have already made an arrest they've
arrested a man in his 40s who were told
was on the water at the time he's been
arrested on suspicion of manslaughter
that's all we know so far though details
still very much sketchy we've had a
statement though from Dorset police
detective Chief superintendent Neil
Corrigan who says our thoughts are with
the loved ones of the young people who
tragically died and we are doing all we
can to support their families I
understand the beach was very busy at
the time of the incident and I would ask
anyone with information that may assist
our inquiries to please come forward so
Dorset please very much hoping that
people who were here at the scene at the
time may be able to assist with their
inquiries because the tragedy will have
unfolded in front of their eyes